one other russia ukraine story i want to
mention this made big headlines over the
last 24 hours and the headline is
russian airstrike has hit
a ukrainian
maternity hospital the associated press
is reporting a russian air strike
devastated a maternity hospital
wednesday in the besieged port city of
mariopol
amid growing warnings from the west that
moscow's invasion is about to take a
more brutal and indiscriminate turn
ukrainian officials said the attack
wounded at least 17 people the ground
shook more than a mile away when the
mario paul complex was hit by a series
of blasts
that blew out windows and ripped away
much of the front of one building
vladimir nikulin a top regional police
official standing in the ruins said
today russia committed a huge crime it
is a war crime without any justification
this story alone is generating a ton of
discussion about what what is the truth
here
on the one hand there was the reaction
that russia is now deliberately bombing
uh maternity hospitals and we saw the
hit the air strike against an orphanage
last week uh and against the children's
hospital last week so one perspective is
they're doing this on purpose to wreak
havoc and cause terror the counterpoint
was it is of no advantage whatsoever to
putin to deliberately strike a maternity
hospital what would be the point
obviously russia doesn't think that
pregnant mothers and health care workers
and newborn babies are the ones waging
the war against them so they would never
deliberately hit
a maternity hospital if they did it must
be indifference or lack of precision
however the the latest that i've read is
russia is claiming that the maternity
ward
was being used as a stage as a staging
area
for
ukrainian troops and volunteers etc and
that there were not actually any
pregnant women in the maternity ward at
the time and that when ukraine says our
maternity ward was hit that it's merely
propaganda because everybody knows that
it's actually a military staging area
do we ultimately know the truth
uh maybe
maybe i i certainly don't know it right
now and i'm open to it being any of the
above that i just mentioned but i think
the most important takeaway from
individual stories like this uh are that
it is complete and total chaos
and
that this is still an optional invasion
by russia and so it's very easy you know
i look at these discussions that happen
online and people are getting
extraordinarily flustered and angry with
each other and adversarial over no no
this was obviously deliberate
no no no obviously russia would never
deliberately hit a maternity ward it
goes against their strategic objectives
and it goes against their pr objectives
as well
i don't think we know and one of the
things that we are seeing is when folks
get involved in the minutia and i'm not
saying we don't care whether a maternity
ward was hit obviously we do and
obviously people are getting wounded and
people are dying and 17 wounded is
supposedly the number uh from this
particular incident when you get bogged
down in the details the point is
you end up fighting with people assuming
that they're good faith actors now if
they're just tr you know russian trolls
pro-russian trolls okay then then it's
uh that's a different story but when you
get bogged down in the in the specifics
of what happened in this one incident
it's very easy to lose the main thread
which is this is an optional
premeditated
invasion of aggression of ukraine
by russia
and when we end up arguing with people
about
would would russia deliberately do this
if they knew that there were not
actually ukrainian troops there or if
they did or whatever
we end up missing that big picture and
that's the big picture that we have to
remember and and quite frankly going
back to the previous segment i did
that big picture of an optional
premeditated invasion of aggression by
russia to try to take land or to install
a puppet government whatever ultimately
is putin's goal
that's the big picture that has united
the west and american allies and nato
allies and so we want to know what
happened here we do and it matters what
happened here
it doesn't change the big picture of
what's going on in the region and i
think that's the important takeaway
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman